dj khaled what's good what's good theo
what's good brendan what's up playboy
shout out
i mean from brooklyn feel me um this is
a debate club question but before that i
want to get some of my akas out there
you know what i mean
john daly in the beautiful brown
stallion aka
girf over worth aka sikkim on your
favorite thickem
aka [ __ ] [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
um i always saw joe rogan as the oprah
that i mean first man holding it down
you feel me amen
and the big club man joe [ __ ]
renegade youtube taking over rogan
or [ __ ] oprah billy nina billy
goat
winfrey feel me um choose wisely y'all
special shout out to y'all man keep
doing your thing
girth girl birth birth or whatever the
[ __ ]
yeah you didn't know what to say gang
man but i like that that's fine yep i
like that you didn't even know what to
say you kept on saying yeah you stuck
with it bro
yeah that's nice that's nice that you
you know just weren't afraid to just put
do whatever and put it out there man
respect
that's a great question man that's a
good question so he's saying
oprah or rogan yeah i think like most
influential
kind of well for the bros can you name
another person's more influence did he
say man though or do you say overall
he just said he just said joe rogan or
oprah
i'm gonna say for influential i'm gonna
say
joe rogan me too because
i mean you know how dude i could throw a
[ __ ] nickel right now and hit 45
[ __ ] dudes
yeah you know white belts who are
[ __ ] you know grilling tattooed up
and on trt
yeah grilling ostrich neck on the
[ __ ] yeah full of
alpha brains in their backyard alpha
brain dog
you know what i'm saying like i could
[ __ ] i could hit a nickel
i could hit 50 of those so inspirational
like
and think how many people joe's put on
now oprah put on you know
dr phil came from him but that's really
it that's about it
oprah probably could have put a lot more
people on she's a selfish [ __ ]
well i don't and i don't know what she's
like me neither
but she's definitely more of the
hollywood side of things
you know i think she's a great
interviewer i think she has a great
voice
but oprah couldn't interview like elon
musk like joseph rogan
no rogan have elon musk on the joey diaz
then my dumbass you know what i'm saying
yeah and they're all entertaining yeah
yeah i think it's and also think if
people go on that show it's
everything can be edited you know and
also if you want rogan's you're [ __ ]
oh you say something bad and you'd be
like hey man can you take this out no
yeah he doesn't edit anything the other
thing is is think about
all the people rogan's put on their
careers
think about it everybody in here pretty
much
everybody in here think about it sagura
used to open for him joey diaz
ian edwards and we can go through all
them are you sure
what do you say duncan trump duncan
trussell i mean there's so many [ __ ]
people
also but although the people that he's
put on other people also like
i mean a lot of comedians have also been
working their career like you know i'm
not going to
he gave him a platform right gave him a
platform oh no don't i'm not saying that
they wouldn't have made it without him
because the the talent's undeniable
like you coming on firing the kid you
the
your talent whether you came on firing
the kid or you came on rogan or you came
on
you know schultz is brilliant idiots
your talent would have came through no
matter what
we're just i was just fortunate to have
you a phone call away
right come on finding the kid but you're
also welcome you know
yeah well thank you for having me too no
i'm just kidding i'm serious though
dude thank you guys for having me bro i
wouldn't be podcasting today if you guys
didn't have me on there yeah
you took over our studio you know that's
true man you know
you know what you moved in you know what
popped up on my story the other day on
youtube you know
there's an algorithm our first episode
ever together and
at fox oh yeah i was old and you and i
didn't know each other i'm like yo
i've heard good nothing but good things
about you yeah i gotta go yeah
you watch some of it and you were
pushing like your album
oh the hamster bones yeah yeah that's a
good album dog
and you're like you're like i'm at fish
and chips stand up this week four
shows i was like god damn theo is a
different dude
you rich rich now man i'm not that rich
man i mean i got 200 on my neck
four actually it's 400 300 100. um yeah
a thousand in your butt
i'll say that's true i got a thousand in
my dog
people like how rich are you i'm going
to make the cops search the next time i
get pulled over i'm just literally going
to bend over
that's when you [ __ ] are pretty gay i
think yeah if you just they don't even
try to search you and you get out and
just bend over and have money in your
butt
uh but did you just say happy easter
that's the worst bro
uh i would definitely say rogan yeah and
i think you're also asking two men's
like if he's asking women's it might be
different you know
even women's now though of course our
fans 1910.
yeah but a lot of men um
think of this rogan doesn't need it but
think if rogan was like yo
i'm starting a podcast network so anyone
who's going to start a podcast before
everyone
and their mom had a podcast he created a
network and had all those people under
his branch
dog he'd be making more money than
spotify pays him
yeah what do you mean he doesn't move
like that though yeah he's like i'm not
trying to own anything you guys do your
own thing
and also once you start doing it all
becomes more work too more
i think it was smart yeah he played it i
mean he
he knows what he's doing just staying
with what he's good at
hey he just loves what he does i mean he
said he he just should hear his plans
for uh
austin really i can't put it out there
like that because he asked me not to
talk about it but dog
when he tells you like oh [ __ ] damn game
changer
well it's good for us because we'll have
a spot to go to in austin you know it's
gonna be a hub now for comedy
you have la austin nashville and uh new
york
that's like the hubs that cap city was
getting a little bit ratchet
yeah um dude but uh what else i thinking
yeah and then oprah though like oprah
will put you i don't know
joe kind of turned oprah was kind of
before rogan though
in a weird way right but she was way
before
but her popularity even because then it
was like ellen kind of came
after oprah remember because it used to
be she used to be on at like three
o'clock
my aunt used to have it on every day
after school totally and she had a book
club in any book club she suggested just
blew the [ __ ] up kind of like rogan you
know right suggests
you know you know how him and on it got
started the owner of on it
aubry came on at the time there was no
on it and he came on to push fleshlights
and so they pushed fleshlights and it
just sold out like a [ __ ]
then aubry's like yo man we should do
this alpha brain these nootropics
together
and so rogan pushed that and they
literally couldn't fulfill the orders
fast enough damn
and then now it's on it on it you know
so like
[ __ ] alpha brain when joey
sells it bro tip top magoo
[Music]
is